they want us to give money for this time
folks Oh Eddie Bracken I like him do you
mind if I get real serious for a moment
I'd like to talk to you about the sixth
wall on drive the boys the plant tell me
the war's almost over now I know a lot
of people are going around saying that
the war is almost over but the fact of
the matter is but even after we clean up
on the Nazis who are holding out we
still have the Japanese who are holding
all this territory here believe it or
not Pacific front is going to cost even
more than the European front for
instance a guy from the Treasury
Department told me had to shipped the
same amount of freight to the South
Pacific cost 25 percent more than it did
to Europe and I have to tell you that
we'll need more b-29 super tanks landing
barges gasoline and oil to fight Japan
but did you ever stop to think that
we'll also need more Italian aid
stations hospital ships convalescent
centers in this sixth wall on Drive
we've got to buy war bonds we've got to
buy more war bonds than we ever did
before gee he's right
yeah but can we afford to brother you
can't afford not to
he's asleep now his name is Johnny
private first class badly wounded on
Saipan as a nurse's aide I see many
cases like this most of them are
strangers to me but Johnny we were kids
together Johnny took me to my first high
school dance I'm knowing Johnny I feel I
know all the boys here you see they're
my generation part of my world my fun I
hope someday all the boys and girls will
come back home no not all of them but
those that do you can help bring them
back soon by buying a share of their
faith and victory by buying a war bond
you know they used to talk about the
Lost Generation the forgotten generation
of generations without hope
but not Jonny's challenge please be like
Johnny
he didn't think he'd have to fight so
many battles but he went right on giving
a little extra courage so let's all of
us to put in something extra - and by
that bond beyond the one we played
surely that isn't too much to do for a
fighting generation